since going live so as we're going live
says we're live
all right think we're live I think we're
good yeah looks like we're good
hello everyone and welcome to round
table with the stream team this is where
we talked to some amazing content
creators about their transition into the
content creator world and where they are
today I would like to welcome today to
our roundtable a ptk blam how are you
doing man how are things I am fantastic
man just happy to be on the show man
shout out to everybody in the chat it
was a great opportunity I love what you
guys are doing so I know you guys are
part of that like iron Lords you know
that that big circle that they got going
on over there so appreciate everything
you guys on but I'm extremely excited
man just glad to be here I'm not well
I'm happy you were able to come on and
you know I said like I was saying I saw
your excitement Twitter and you were
like how would I come on I was like I
want you here I was like I want people
here that wanna be here and they want to
talk and I want to chat and I was like
fantastic it's gonna be great
so that's great I can't wait to ask you
a bunch more questions so we got today
l-boogie how are you I'm pretty good
just chillin all right and we and we got
the little little man MJ is a boss right
now yeah finally gets away from his
college life for for an hour and this
time I have the webcam on oh look at
that and the beard it's it's crazy I
it's full dude your beauty hacks was so
patchy super patchy
yeah and now it's dude that's a good
beard it's gonna come out its gonna come
full it's gonna be good I'm gonna give
you some some beard regiment stuff for
when back in the day when I when I had
one so anyway while we are what we're
all here for is to see PT k blam how are
you
what is going on and what started making
you want to get into this content
creator realm well first and foremost
I'm great
fantastic just working you know
obviously just got off work like an hour
hour and a half ago obviously working on
the channel as well so just to answer
your first question um what got me into
it I just to start for the beginning
I've been doing YouTube for about three
and a half going on four years
um fairly successful I'd say in my eyes
I guess but what started me was honestly
back in 2013 you know when the new
consoles first came out all I was
getting all my news from IgA and the big
websites and I didn't necessarily agree
with the information that they were
putting out so I'm like whoa is there
anywhere else that I can find this new
so I went to YouTube and all these other
places and there was really no you know
nobody else speaking you know I'm an
Xbox fan if you didn't know sorry guys
check everything but I'm a star so it's
okay yeah so you know but either way um
I was just looking for some information
and I have found very few people that
provided the information or just a
different opinion you know what I'm
saying so I decided well why the hell
not I have I have a voice I have a
computer I have all these things to make
you know these videos and put out my own
information his final thoughts so that's
kind of what got me started and then I
found Twitter which opened up my eyes
because once I hit Twitter I realized
there's other people out there and
there's a larger community that I can
reach that have you know even they don't
have that the same opinion but we're
talking about the same kinds of things
so that's kind of what got me into it
then I found other content creators you
know the kind of kind of snowball from
there so the other content creators that
you kind of have gravitated towards are
they like friends of yours or they just
people that you found when you were just
on Twitter or people that you know enjoy
each other's company is their what what
well they became friends over time um
name a few next-gen was like a very
first person I found next in 720 um that
just randomly found them crap obviously
a couple of other people I'm at the time
I don't know if you remember I don't
fear even doing podcast back like that
long ago but um there was very little
there was no podcast really at that
there was really not a community so they
were they were doing the first one so
those guys and moved away then me a
mooch fun fact
together before you started a podcast I
didn't know he was on the podcasts he'll
me and him just randomly were talking in
a party chai one day on xbox and he's
like yeah I'm doing his podcast called
BTS he I'm like you and I watched it so
we ended up it was kind of cool but
either way these are people that have
built friendships with over time so Tim
doll
my very first podcast another didi was
my first guest um and being Aaron
Greenberg was actually my first guest on
my very first pocket um so that was
incredibly fun but uh yeah just people
that I mean draft hey I mean I gotta let
me pick these up on the floor for you
shut up attic in the chat oh that's
what's going on dude lurking probably
from work oh yeah that's kind of how it
kind of snowballed from there just
building relationships and a lot of that
had to do with just Twitter a lot of
that came from talking to people
consistently on Twitter and then
realizing hey these guys make youtube
videos well that's great that's great so
when you started your YouTube channel it
was it just the YouTube channel itself
or do you go hey I'm gonna go straight
for the podcast it was just a channel I
just wanted to do videos you know just
normal videos gaming videos
informational videos like I actually
wanted to do gameplay and I love with my
very first thought I just want to put up
gameplay and then I realized I don't
know if I want to do that so I thought
I'm I do the information thing pretty
good let's try that so it's kind of the
direction I'm going ever since so still
no gameplay on the channel um it hasn't
you know been a bad thing because I
enjoy what I do now so yeah I just
really do the informational videos for
the most part then now the podcast kind
of come along after about probably like
four or five months they're doing just
regular videos the podcast I popped up
so at what point did you decide that you
were going to produce the podcast and
have multiple cast mates to go to go
forward with it
um to be honest with you after the after
that show with with tenth with Tim and
Aaron and you know Chris and everybody
um I saw the you know that it was
extremely fun you know it was really fun
stolen ideas back before I figured out
you know what let me try my hand at
putting the panel together and doing
it's not like a weekly basis and that's
what I threw out the idea and I my
podcast is don't like I don't know maybe
four or five different iterations but
I'm really happy or it's at now but
that's I say that was the first
realization and hey I could probably do
this every week so mm-hmm so the the
shot podcast yeah where did you come up
with that name because that is I think a
very you note name for a podcast
well my thinking is we the kind of
conversation we have we have in a barber
shop you know that's just that's kind of
where it came from and I just took the
barber off I do rags and crazy stuff but
yeah so I figured that's the kind of
conversation we have so it fit you know
and kind of in in a barber shop if you
think about it the environment you talk
about everything you know just whatever
somebody brings up it just kind of comes
up so and that's kind of how I like to
keep the show so if you if you ever
watch the show chat or you know anybody
here on a panel that's kind of the tone
that I like to keep on a show it's just
real casual it's just it kind of flows
it kind of you know everything kind of
flows and builds on itself so that's
kind of where I got the name from yeah
cuz when I cuz I have checked out a you
know a couple of episodes and the the
way that your panel is it is super
mellow because a lot of the podcasts
that you know have been like you know in
the buzz if you will or more of those
like in-your-face like what's going on
this is the news this is what's
happening this is what's going on but
you guys seem like a group of group of
individuals that are just like chill I
just hanging out just be like hey did
you hear about what happened with Xbox
today how they kind of broke you know so
it's like things like that where I was
just very mellow relaxing and it was it
was very reassuring because most I feel
like most people who are kind of like
you know this is what it is this is
what's happening and it's more like
propaganda and things like that so I I
thought it was very good I thought you
know I recommend everyone should go and
check out the shop podcast it's really
good it's really good I I like I like
the way that you guys have in your four
for your your podcast thank you that
outcome meds and lady infamous or
stopping behind the chat says shout out
to PD and is that my little bro MJ you
already know J is like the the resident
little brother for everybody okay so so
you just do the videos you just do the
the podcast itself you don't do
streaming you don't do anything like
that you just do the podcast then right
for the most part yeah I write at this
particular point at one point it was a
mix between podcast and just regular
weekly videos then obviously life
happens I'm with Mary they have two kids
I work a full-time job you know all
these different things happened so I
couldn't do the floor time videos you
know I couldn't commit to doing it
consistently if I'm not gonna be able to
do it consistently I'm not gonna do it
at all yeah so I know I can do the
podcast consistently so that's why
that's continued and to be honest with
you alright that's kind of like my
fixity you know yeah that's kind of how
our casting that kind of rolls into you
know the way I put it together it's like
we all feel the same way about Amy and
that's why this works with the guys I
put on the show and you know it's all
kind of I mean you know it's we have the
same mind but you know the way we showed
a lot video games um you know are very
very similar so it's been a phenomenal
phenomenal ride but yeah that's kind of
how I put three piece things together as
far as my content in the way I do it
yeah how no you said you have your three
kids I have two your two kids yeah
how did like how did your wanting to go
through the podcast and the videos has
it affected them when you were like hey
I'm gonna go I'm gonna start doing this
well they were well my daughter cheated
really she was indifferent though I mean
they're both teenagers now they're
fifteen or fourteen they're both I
sports is particular point so my son no
he's been playing video games as he was
zero so like literally so he came out
the womb sitting on a last playing Halo
so he's always into it and he thought it
was a cool idea my wife I'm extremely
lucky she
pushed me to do this so when I was 14
and rag on my feet she actually bought
all the equipment and I came home one
day from work she's like you said you
want to do this here is all the stuff
dude so she put me to do it and I really
really appreciate that my family's man
ultra supportive they love what I do
they've come to appreciate what you know
just a little bit of entertainment I
provided whatever comes and watches the
podcast they've been really supportive
about it all right yeah well that's
that's that's fantastic because I know
that some people they end up having
those people on like the family members
that are kind of like very awkward and
they're not sure how they're gonna react
and and it's really nice to see here
that they ended up wanting to back you
up and support you through that absolute
process so so how did you get Aaron
Greenberg to get onto a podcast that was
random as hell um oh what happened was
we start this Joe and me and Tim were
sitting there were going through the
show and we ended up talking about we
got on this topic of I like ritual games
right and so um I don't know where I get
this both Tim got the message and then
Tim messaged me saying because he don't
want to say it in ops ey we were talking
like did you Aaron Greenberg just Dan me
said hey and I'm like what do you mean
like that guy like that he's like yes
that air he said he's listening and how
does he get in a show and I'm like what
do you mean get me so he wants to come
on he's like he's like yes and I'm like
okay you're bullshitting stop playing
and I did not believe him at all so then
he's I know for sure like like shoot of
a message and you know whatever whatever
so I shot him a message he hit me right
back saying yeah man I don't I don't
know how to get in can you city elite
I'm like oh yeah I'll send you a link so
um it took a little while to get in I
didn't think he's actually gonna come
but he actually just jumped in he
actually brought up Chris with him as
well money rumble the Gaudi does fan
fest I hit a fan he came in as well so
that's kind of it just I don't know why
he was listening I'm not entirely sure
maybe somebody said but he just ended up
listening and wanted to join he said he
liked what I was talking about him what
we were talking about he just wanted to
talk
so that's what happened it was very down
to earth yeah this super random huh
that's pretty amazing so you so you've
been doing your podcast well
consistently now for five years yeah cuz
I've taken a couple breaks and long
hiatus so yeah like yeah of everything
you know so what did you [ __ ] what did
you feel was necessary when you decided
that you wanted to to start this well
like what did you well if you say that
you went out you and you went out and
picked up the hold of your gear and
stuff like that did you just pick up
like a nice mic and a nice PC what did
you what you end up doing a comic page
yourself coming and starting my wife did
so once again out at work yeah yeah my
wife did she so she just went balling a
laptop my headset on solar stuff a hard
drive external all that except was like
hey this is what you really want to do
you said you want to do it this is like
a start obviously over time you build up
but that was just to get me going you
don't care to get my feet on the ground
but yeah that's essentially what
happened I came home because we were
talking about it it launches she's like
you're are you gonna go do that today
and I'm like and you know just kind of
putting it on flame I'm still thinking
about it kind of creating ideas and I
got home she's like boom boom here's
everything you need to do this as you
said you've been trying to do it so
that's pretty awesome that's pretty cool
they said you know she was you know
backing up that much they really like
you come home and it's like a present
it's a laptop yeah sitting right there
what is this like everything you said
you wanted to get started on your
YouTube so here you go oh great that's
great yeah what what what do you end up
doing to make sure that you had growth
in your channel because you you know
you've had some pretty decent growth
before for the podcast your channel for
everything so the funny thing about
YouTube is that when I first started
that was my life I was a numbers I was
always I was like refreshing my videos
every like 10 seconds you know you gotta
fall into this thing where you just get
infatuated with numbers but um I think
the biggest thing for e I just wanted to
be consistent it like put out quality
content as best as the qualities I could
because once again I'm not the most tech
guy you know I'm
self-taught you know as far as like
editing videos and things like that so
I'm not like you're not gonna get you
know like certain levels of quality out
of me unfortunately but I did the best I
can so quality was first and
inconsistency was a second one so I had
to find kind of a balance between the
two you know in between my real life
work family and everything like that so
those two things for me were first and
foremost and then third was being
different I didn't want to put out the
same kind of content that everybody else
was putting out you know at the time
there was not very many podcasts or
people doing videos it was very very
little you know content so now there's a
podcast three podcasts every single day
of the week
back then it was picking one to podcast
week so I didn't have to really fight
for the space but I just wanted to be
you know unique and put out unique
topics and I'm a lot of times I just
come up with topics on the fly like I
don't even I'll take a something that
happened in the news and I'll put my own
little spin on it or something and maybe
I thought about it you know a lot of my
drive comes from one people to just
think about you know what I'm talking
about just trying to push people to
think you know I said pushing for the to
talk and have conversations about
different things that maybe they you
didn't think about before so quality
consistency and then just get your email
cool cool
so what what do you think is like the
first gaming like type memory you have
of when you when you started because you
know we're all gamers here and we all
enjoy doing like you know obviously
that's that's why we're all pretty much
in this type of you know content creator
business if you will so like was it the
first memory you can have like a you
remember of when you were gaming as a
kid um my first memory that I had gaming
as a kid um probably um did you see oh
gee Nintendo probably do gee no honestly
um I was a Sega kid growing up once the
Sega came out it was a rat that's all I
wanted that was it
so but the og Nintendo um my fondest
gaming was playing you guys remember
Excitebike oh yeah
you know we tell you how to flip and
fill right on my head that in us a turn
I universe catered eyes yeah I do and as
no I had too big my grandma I begged her
to buy me the arcade control you know
the big block older with the turbo
buttons on her buttons with the tote it
was the really like of this big yeah it
was you guys like six pounds or
something crazy but I begged her to buy
me that just because I wanted to do like
some particular moves on the game so she
bought it from my birthday so that's
probably one of the earliest games I had
was the og Nintendo fantastic that's
awesome Abbi that's great so what are
you what are you playing now oh man um I
can get time shout-out to my party
we play a lot of division together yeah
yeah that updates coming out tomorrow
come on Xbox everything no that's the
24th - oh but you have a pics coming out
with their holiday thing oh you're right
fortnight is doing everything tomorrow
morning it's supposed to be cool what
you expected it was weird I was like
what is going on here and then I was
like man they're about to make everybody
sit here and watch this [ __ ] for hours
and that's exactly what they did I'm
like great I'm not watching this like
it's still the number no it's still
number one on mixer I'm being watched
oh yeah it's do you have to admit one
thing about that begins there stuff that
they're doing for fortnight is amazing
good yes it's that the idea to unplug
everybody yeah like at the same time
like a literally a worldwide scale
unplug is genius
gene yeah the creativity I feel like the
creativity from them
is pretty good on that side of stuff
yeah I think that's really good yeah but
yes I'm excited about Division two
tomorrow I can't probably a problem
sleeping tonight really just grind and
play so that my son's been playing a lot
of Apex he's actually making you want to
play bad now cuz I wasn't really you
know playing yeah playing you aren't you
aren't you huge into that yeah like it's
one of the it's the only burial that
I'll play by myself
oh yeah that's that says something too
because I can't get into like those
games solo there's no way I can do with
solos yeah aren't they having like a new
map or something to do it
they've already added in your map we're
doing like a Halloween thing which gives
you overwatch mimes because it basically
gave all the characters special
Halloween outfits
ah and then they're having a special
mode where like your ghost I guess so
you like look fuzzy and have glowing
eyes and everything yeah that's
interesting that's interesting I hope
good no so just those for the most part
though so I'm probably gonna pick up a
pics here we'll we'll see what's going
over live but um you know division ATX
those it's really due to I've been
playing late that's awesome no do you
play apex with it with your son all
you're gonna assume you don't play with
your son as of yet no not as yet I'm
going to though just watching him like
get into it a bike he's really easy he's
amazing by the way he like he makes me
look like dog crap
slow-motion did he follow and you're
like gaming footsteps because he sees
how much you enjoy playing absolutely
absolutely
his mother does he never fails to tell
me that he's a product of me for sure so
but yeah he said he since he was 1z no 9
was 8 much whatever you want to say he's
been just sitting watching you play
video games whether it's Pro listed on
my lap I handed him a controller at
probably three years old you know play
just play on his own system or this I
put him in a game like Halo or something
he
just run around whatever so he just been
on it ever since
III want to eventually win when me and
my wife have kids what I want to do is
like I want to hand my child like like
the hardest videogame so I want to hand
it like in television and just be like
here I want to learn and then we'll
proceed forward we'll eventually get you
to the Xbox
I want you to do I want you to beat
Legend of Zelda me no no no how old how
old am I yeah reveal reveal coming up
I'm 37 okay let me know unless you're
having a child this year you're gonna be
so tired that you do not care what that
child is you're not gonna be like beat
Legend of Zelda and all that other mess
you're just gonna look just don't talk
to me alright well we'll see I'll put a
camera on gonna be asking you for all
these new games many of you buying them
form the way consolidates what I can buy
so oh man so uh kind of go back to the
gaming subject so with the the games
you're playing do you do you play any
like couch co-op games or anything like
that or is it just mostly the online
games just those just those two really
um no um me and what so this is so you
may laugh at this I don't know you may
or may not so my most played game this
entire generation has probably been
plans for zombies - garden warfare 2 so
me and my wife played again that's
that's like kind of like me and her time
you don't say I said we'll play that a
lie he's actually really good at it
she's really good at video games in
general she has her own Xbox her own TV
our own headset or all controllers all
that kind of stuff so she made sure that
happened matter of fact I met my wife
playing Tekkit funny story but either
way um so yeah I'm kind of I'm kind of
intrigued but oh I was at I was at my
best friend's house and she just moved
in next door to him and I was like who
is that he's like what she's nude I'm
okay I'm gonna be over here more often
and then we just just through being
around and you know being in a
neighborhood and I just just started
talking you know because we have mutual
friends it's like that and realize she
has to play video games went to her
house it's all she owned a Playstation
you play Tekken and it just kind of grew
from there we used to just play against
each other all the time and then so yeah
that's kind of this kind of how it
started and it's random you didn't
realize he was even a gamer until I
exceed went to her house and saw does he
owned a Playstation and we just played
together ever since
you could be honest she whooped you
every time she know she so I'ma be
honest I'm not even all to appear lie it
was pretty close
you know that's he got a couple games
off me she did she used to use King
knows you could always just slam me
everytime like say what are you doing
like it's hard to play against people
you know that is right
yeah he's one that's it so um but no she
was she's amazing at video games but
that's kind of our little side story of
how I met um let's go but ya know it's
what so so garden warfare 2 was you know
a thing so the new one came out that
we're getting that so we'll probably get
back into that download the damn thing
um but yeah so that's kind of what we do
that's our time but as far as that I'm
usually fine with you know a couple guys
for the podcast or just whatever's
online at that point so and then that's
really division 2 and um apex of which
is gonna be now I was really into uh I
played a ton of games I have my PI
backlog is crazy I just like all of our
so that's not anything new but um oh I
can't even think
do you feel like that there's too many
games that are coming out too quickly
no no I mean you can only play so much I
mean we all have other things you have
to do so you pick and choose what you
want to play I don't buy everything you
know I'm saying so a lot you know the
funny thing the good thing about this
generation or is a lot of the
free-to-play games are really good like
the apex is the fort I see that you can
get a lot of legs out of those game
shoot with game paths from the free
games every month you don't necessarily
even need to buy really nowadays they
don't just wait pay a little game pass
bill if you have it or place a Chanel
and just do that you know I'm saying so
it's really really cost-effective now to
play those games so I'm I'm actually
looking to probably once it'll cuz I
have a huge gaming backlog right now but
once my giving backlog kind of you know
- dies down I'm gonna pick up the PC
version of what's a cult game pass
because okay I really want to play see
if these cuz oh I've never played it
before and it looks so good and I'm like
it's extremely fun and who ended up kind
of turning me on to want to play that is
when I was watching l-boogie play oh you
were playing with somebody else and I
just remember seeing you guys go through
a volcano and I was like see if these oh
yeah all you you and your friends were
doing was just laughing and just bugging
out and I was just like this is looks
like one of those party games there
could be a lot of fun to hang out with
your friends with shut up - mostly in
the chat thanks for stopping by nice
definitely no bookie can probably tell
you better than I have I probably
haven't played in nearly as much as she
has but it's it's a fun game was
extremely underrated man they've done a
lot of good things with that game you
know a lot of things find at the radar
with that thing still is consistently in
the top 20 on mixer on twitch now people
really enjoy playing it's a fun game to
stream as well
yeah no reason why I stopped because now
he has like they would make certain
events where he had to play with random
people and I didn't like that
you will give these people that would
help you until the end and then just run
in the back of the head and take your
crap yeah that is not fun like it's been
hours doing something people griefing
you yeah yeah yeah I really I hate games
like that that have that option that you
can kind of just turn on your buddies
like were last minute if you thought hey
I need it it's so again it's so bad
well are you uh you plan on going any
conventions or anything this year me
yeah um
oh my three is on my list next year um
III for sure I'm out here on the west
coast essentially so um that's doable as
far as Ike
you know PAX East and all that kind of
stuff I'd like to do that at some point
those are all on a bucket list but
realistically e3 is probably gonna be
the event that's at the top of the list
I'm definitely doing that um depending
on if I have to go visit family next
year I'm that will determine whether or
not I actually go to I definitely want
to do it because we don't get these new
consoles every so often we get them
every five six seven years so the fact
that we're gonna see these things next
year is like oh my god I have to I
almost have to make time to go so I'm
shooting for e3 next year then I'll see
you there
oh nice going mm-hmm you ready now oh
dude okay I was the most most of us I
think want to go next year because of
those and almost every single person
we've had on the cast said they're good
they want to go to e3 next year you know
with those big drops of all those
consoles and everything going on it's
gonna be so much better and it's gonna
be so much vibrant and all those
Playstations should be there if they're
not there okay you heck amazed because I
can understand why they didn't want to
go last year but at the same time like
if they don't go yeah next year I think
it's gonna be like it's gonna be hurtin
for them to do just to not do that I
think it's gonna be a terrible decision
I think they will I think they know they
haven't done anything as far as a show
for like an entire calendar year it
hasn't been a PSX know anything the only
thing they've gotten is a state of play
so I think that you know they're they're
ramping up you know both companies are
so they're neither one is gonna let
either one get too much of a head start
you know so I fully expect Sony to show
up and show out like they pretty much
always do yeah
so when have you gone to any other
conventions before just III or you've
never not I have not so that's it's on
the bucket list I'm saying there's all
these events that I want to go to even
like a comic-con like that that are
actually out here in my city fairly
regularly like every year they're out
here I'm not never going any of those
events I have to go there all on my list
so have you have you noticed on your
podcast I know I'm kind of tripping
topics there's just something I got
popped in my head but have you noticed
any topics that you guys like brought up
that kind of like impress you with your
with your viewer count or anything like
that it's I don't say specific topics
you know make the viewer count jump or
anything like that is fairly random I
think just if people have time to watch
that week you know a lot of times my
show is on a Saturday evening say well 6
o'clock my time so it's late for you
guys out on the East Coast is still 9:00
so I don't know if ideally I have the
right time slot but you know everybody
is there's a lot of consistent people
that do come last week a bunch of new
people just randomly out of nowhere so I
think a lot of it has to do with people
having time to watch the show I it was
originally on Fridays but then I my
schedule changed so I didn't have a
choice to Saturdays um but a lot of the
people that were watching Fridays moved
to Saturdays as well so I get a lot of
regulars on the show but the last
probably two months I've been getting a
ton of new people which is really
excited for me because I you know that
means things are growing that means
other people are seeing the content so
that's me really excited but it's
specific topics I mean I'm not really
into it I don't do the click place so
you'll never have clicked face up you'll
never see the theatrics you'll never see
you know the WWE is what I like to call
it a lot of WWE podcasts out so now I'm
not any names or tone any shade you know
but there's a lot of that and I just
like try to be authentic
we know just who I am or whatever so I
mean that doesn't necessarily attract
the biggest number but the people that
are there enjoy the show and that's what
that's what matters
yeah so when when we decided that you
know when me how we're sitting down and
we're talking back and forth and we were
like well what time frame will be good
for us and I was like well like this day
wouldn't be that good for for this
reason this day wouldn't be good for
this reason and and he was at wall he's
like if they're all gonna be kind of you
know not the best options and he's like
why don't you talk to the rest of your
panel and see when we'll be good and and
it seems like it's a general consensus
that one day it would be good and I was
it that's all right let's do it Monday
that kind of works for everyone it's
kind of the start of a work week you
know everyone's kind of chill and
relaxed and stuff like that and after I
think the first or second week cog was
like you know what I realized you did
and I said what did we do he goes it's
Monday Night Football and I was like
yeah sports yeah anywhere I'm like I
don't I don't I don't really mind sports
that much but I was like I was like so I
think that it the numbers that you're
getting all right or it might not be
from the live shows more of the people
that like oh I want to watch this and
they're gonna be able to watch it
throughout the whole week yeah that's
true yeah that's how that's how I kind
of felt it was yeah and that's something
as a content creating a tachometer
because sometimes your success your
vision is a lot bigger than reality and
so you can get that's something that can
work against you if you're not like if
you don't realize you know okay let me
take a step back and figure out where
I'm going I'm sure you know boogie as
well as you know a lot of us here make
content you obviously um you know
sometimes you get you hit the ground
running and you know things happen you
know things don't happen to the way you
planned it or your vision you could have
everything meticulously planned out okay
this time this day for this specific
reason but it doesn't always work out
that way so you got to be comfortable
with that and just fall back on you know
consistency fall back on quality fire
back and and trust the content you're
putting out so I had to get over that
hurdle a couple times as well but once I
found my bruise I I'm
really really really really steady on
you know where my channel was going and
the people that do show up and I
appreciate every single person that does
you know come out and watches for
whatever reason they watch you know do
you feel like the the where your show is
gone you know you're happy you feel
successful you feel like it's a yeah it
was good
absolutely Absalom completely
comfortable war I'm at now and it's
actually when I decided to change my
mindset that's when I felt like to show
that better you know I'm saying well I
wasn't so focused on numbers and
analytics because YouTube throws that in
your face right away like YouTube throws
e analytics right in your face so you
can get over that hurdle I've became
extremely comfortable I'm really
comfortable with the people that are on
the show the panel I got a lot of great
relationships in the community like you
know I'm able to reach out to certain
people and get them on the show or just
have a decent relationship you know
we're building one right now you know
prior to now never had a conversation so
this is really really cool for me but
I'm extremely happy where I'm at and
it's just it's grown since then because
I felt like I've kind of settled in and
just focus on the right things for me at
least personal yeah yeah I'm I'm hot
like I said before I was happy that you
know you want to come on and I and I
feel like when when we decided we were
gonna do something like this it was a
real nice place to culminate a lot of
people to be able to meet other people
meet other contractors be to their you
know people who have different opinions
and things like that and it's it's
fantastic it's great yeah absolutely
that's what as far as well we that's
what we do this I love having a show
even returning guests that have been on
multiple times or brand new people
doesn't make me a difference I just I
enjoy the the forum know what did you
start off with once you first like set
up your podcast like what type of mic
and something up oh just a headset I had
a headset that I had heard just a
logitech it did the job at the time then
I switch to a headset I've upgraded
headsets over time obviously upgraded
mics things like that but that's just
just Logitech then I had a gaming
headset at the time it was like a turtle
beach why
when got mean why could I say the
external hard drive a laptop AC really
the problem is your research looks
pretty good so I was like but that was
what I started out with just something
to get me going and then things have
kind of grown so said you kind of build
it up as you kind of know the direction
at your channel you wanna go and it
depends on how serious you take it as
well but if you don't take it seriously
you're probably not gonna invest in it
oh I'm pretty sure you over there with
you know if like five screens and you
have three so you guys know exactly what
I'm talking about you know um so that's
kind of what I started out with though
just in the beginning and it's I mean
you don't really need much to skit start
it and that's a lot of times people that
da me or ask me questions about that you
don't really need a lot like a mic in
the computer or laptop works just fine
most times you know just to get started
what's what's some advice that you can
give somebody that is just starting the
whole streaming or streaming or even to
just the podcast side of um how far to
go have fun
yeah um that's the biggest thing because
I don't know if you've been through this
as concentrated as we go we go to the
motion um you go through this emotional
rollercoaster with your content you know
so you're really excited then maybe the
numbers don't look good so you get down
you start what am i doing why am I doing
this is my content good enough why are
people not watching me things like that
once you get to that you got to realize
have fun why are you doing this why are
we doing why are we talking right now
because I enjoy talking to you guys
thoroughly I enjoy video games we have
there's a common denominator there so
once you realize oh that's why I'm doing
this
it doesn't feel like a job anymore
because you can really turn this into a
nine-to-five you you really can't not
saying like in that way but you can make
it feel like a day job you get burnt out
not want to do it so once I realize I'm
doing it's just to have fun that's what
I would that's the biggest thing I would
tell somebody is just getting started
yeah there's there's a couple of
concentrators that you know it's in our
circle that they they do like three or
four podcasts a week it's crazy yeah and
like I'm just I'm just like applaud them
because they're doing it because they
love it
yeah that's like you know what I think
is the best thing it's like people are
gonna do these things because they love
doing it yes but you can't recited it
yeah yeah that's that you know and then
eventually you know you'll make this you
know huge Kingdom and then you can just
hand it off to your kids obviously all
of us want to be like you so I mean you
know it is what it is whatever goal you
have whether it be to get assisting
people whether it be to get a subscriber
count or a view count or just just to do
it you know just cuz you think it's fun
to do stick to that goal if you want to
take it seriously obviously you know it
requires investing the biggest thing you
gotta invest is time you know that's
even more than money
you know when invested time money comes
along later you can build up to that
know if you working or whatever you
working scrounge up two dollars you can
build up the money forever but just
invest some time if you take it serious
but not too serious so what you feel
like you're working a full-time job and
okay we're gonna get burnt out you know
all of us take care of our families and
we work regular jobs and you don't want
it to feel that way you know so you want
to come home and be able to decompress
because like I said for me I guess every
week is a like a fix for me you know
what I'm saying like I get my fix by
doing the show and by being on other
podcasts but just have fun don't forget
that you know don't lose sight of why
you start when we when we first were
messaging Tammy each other over Twitter
and I was we were trying to figure out
the timezone situation for us oh I was
just I was just like I was thinking of
myself a Mike
oh man like our podcasts pretty early
for you and my kid is he gonna be able
to make is he not I was I was kind of I
was kind of concerned but once you said
you're like nah we'll be good we'll make
it I was like all right I was like
perfect
because I know it's kind of hard for us
you know us East Coasters to get with
the with the west coast side so MJ did
you have a question I'm sorry wait so
what headset are you using now um I have
a hyper axis the hyper did something
some of the clean mm-hmm first yeah yeah
they were they're really good they're
super comfortable they're well built the
quality is what I like I mean if they
have different birds
now have some really expensive to be
paid at the lower end but they're all
really high quality and I've don't do
about I'm pretty sure we can all test it
going through about 10 different 20
headsets probably break in the year if
not work and whatever the case may be in
these ones I've been phenomenal I bought
two sets one for me one for my wife and
they've been great so I hopefully at
some point I'm gonna shoot them an email
to maybe get some mom maybe the
sponsorship or something that would be
amazing
yeah I I really enjoyable so I use the
razor headsets all the time those things
broke on me like I went through so much
I would go through like one or two like
well not two but like maybe like one
every two years
I was like I'm like these are so
expensive I don't want them to break and
when I got these I ended up picking up
the SteelSeries ones probably about a
year and a half ago and these things are
still working great that the wireless
ones yeah I mean they're worth the money
and I was very very surprised how well
they ended up working once I got the TR
pro amp and I connect to the PC I
haven't had any problem I seriously
think that happen to take your cord in
and out tends to like mess up the system
somehow drugs and then Wireless because
of the frequency they work on and all
the other [ __ ] that we have one like it
usually the signal is always messing up
yeah yeah that's that was the thing that
I wouldn't I with the this headset uh I
actually never plug it into the PC for
it to work I like I plug it in to power
through USB cord like I my phone plugged
in or whatever yes but it still works
wirelessly and I Slevin any problems so
I wonder if that's been helping or not
helping it so L do you have any
questions cuz I'm sitting in or MJ I'm
just sitting here you know chatting and
blind with the guys so so I'm sorry I'm
you know I'm Italian I'm usually you
have to cut the other person off before
you can kind of
so you just got it just gonna go with it
so so what's your like main console you
have the one excerpt of the s or you
know the big one
Oh No so all three or SS I don't have an
exercise I decided because dances work
just fine for me and I decided that like
I'm not gonna make the jump it's rusty
now it's no point now the new systems
are coming out next year so I'm buying
that obviously when that drops scarlet
whatever the name is gonna be so I'm
working with 3s cos right now so that's
that's a perfect setup for me they do
what they're supposed to do they still
get the 4k and you know blu-ray drive
and all that good stuff so I don't get
the the hardware and I don't get the
beefy you know upgrades things like that
but it works for what I needed I didn't
feel the need at the time to just go out
buy a nexus for a graphical update or
power up a power upgrade so I just I'm
cool with what I got now but obviously
next year I'm all over those new
consoles for sure I'm gonna tell you the
vision looks really nice
I know it I know it is right know it
right and I'm not biased or anything but
you know well you play you play on PC
but divisional pieces yeah yeah see you
got scene you're you're speaking from a
different ballpark that I met over here
though so yeah well I have I have
division 2 for PC and I have it also for
my xbox so how look for both so it's not
like I'm sitting there saying I can't
tell the difference because I've seen it
I've seen that I've seen the difference
but L remember how we were talking about
my xbox I finally figured it out I don't
I have an old fat boy I I don't I don't
have the I don't have the yes I have the
of one of the original Xbox ones not not
one of the one yes I have one of the bad
ones
so that might also be part of it that
probably's so what console do you think
you're gonna buy first for next-gen are
you gonna go with the PS 5 or the um
what's a Scarlett cuz that's where all
my you don't you just know so we do this
console war thing and it's so funny
because we're really like 10 year olds
at the playground when it comes to that
because we really odd
the reason I play on xbox is because
that's where all my fridge there's
really no other reason you know I'm
saying so um the psy I'm gonna I'm
looking to get a ps5 as well because my
daughter actually prefers Playstation
because of the JRPGs um the the access
to JRPGs on that system so that's
probably gonna be something I'm we're
probably gonna have more than likely you
gotta get her the switch and you gotta
get our farm yeah yeah mobility and then
obviously should be able to come home
yeah they got a RPG offers it's like
he's a fireman ninokuni and all the
other kind of games so yeah Link's
Awakening was nice how did you did you
ever play the original for Game Boy um I
believe so but no I did so fun fact here
Ocarina times my favorite game or yeah
matter what system though but I didn't
play it on the Gameboy was it on the
Gameboy it was which one you told
ocarina yeah Super Nintendo so will you
tell me when they brought majora's mask
out and you have to like use the full
you have to use the ocarina like every
late hour
you were like I love this yeah do you
you know that there's an app on your
iPhone which is the Zelda Ocarina and
you can play it did you know that you
can buy one from Gamestop I didn't know
that I knew that you could but that's
cheating you can play it wrong like if
you play it like you click the right
notes it like plays the full song and if
you do it wrong it like I don't know it
was pretty cool somebody showed me it'd
be like nerd put me away
no I I
I thought the ocarinas are pretty cool
when they introduce those I was like I
was like that's that that's a really
cool concept because back it was the n64
the first time I introduced the ocarina
right ocarina yeah that was 64 yeah yeah
and you had like the four buttons on the
top it's still cool so do you have any
do you have any more questions no no I
got one so once you said you how Aaron
Greenberg joined a podcast what was your
first up before he joined the podcast
like what was that spike I promote it he
tweeted out um he did he actually did oh
so both of the him and Chris so Tim did
it first and then like whoa what
happened so he came in cuz what happened
Tim was like well I don't know if he's
sure was taken quite a while it was all
you might not even have hang on I'm sure
he anything else so um when he actually
jumped in randomly you can go back and
watch it it's one of the first videos on
my channel
you'll see me like whoa he's actually
here and it did it did shoot up quite a
bit I mean before I was sitting in there
maybe we had 20 people then once he got
in there ended up being like a hundred
and fifty immediately like right away
what the tweet went out so it was it was
pretty surprising and I didn't realize
it till after the show was over we were
just behind the scenes like just in the
lobby talking to him and everybody and
then we you know we everybody left and
I'm looking at my numbers I'm like holy
moly there was that many people in the
show so it didn't hit me right away I
was just so stuck in the moment but I
didn't actually expect him to come in so
it was really really for my very first
okay it was crazy
I was I was blown over your ship the
next podcast as soon as you started it
um I still did pretty good numbers I
don't remember off the top of my head it
was the community oh yeah absolutely I
got off to a great start
Oh
up to a grace that definitely um you
know help me you know get off to a good
start so yeah it was it was I didn't
never ever ever ever think that that was
a thing because I mean when he when he
said that he was watching I went why are
you at first I was would like why
how did that happen like what did you
hide you end up looking at my podcast
this is my first podcast ever so like
this it's not like I had a big community
you know I was known I'm not even sure I
didn't even ask how it happened I still
haven't asked him to this day
how like how he found me and I had that
whole back story once so I'm probably
people ask I could probably be able to
did you ever have the feeling of like
you were like like starstruck like you
were fanboy on something Oh or someone I
should say no no um whoa yeah initially
yeah that that show um some pretty
pretty you know good people on the show
obviously none it's probably as big as
that since then um but no I didn't feel
like I was just trying to keep my
composure like talk straight you know I
mean I was just trying to get the
questions out not sound you know stumble
over words and things like that so it
was more about just kind of being cooled
and asking the questions and obviously
there was things that I couldn't ask
that I wanted to add as we were
afterwards talking I asked a couple
other things that I couldn't ask on air
um you know but um so it just it was one
of those kind of humbling situations
where I'm like man this is actually like
like I feel like man this is something I
never thought evident it happened
immediately bored distracted said ptk
has got connections I don't know I don't
know about that I don't even know how
that happened I don't have to this day
found me and why he watched me what
would he was sitting there cuz he did it
from his office at work he was at at I
guess Xbox up in Seattle Redmond and he
was he was at work and then then he
brought Christian as well money ruffle I
guess they were both in they're having
some kind of meeting and they just both
jumped so they're all hanging out having
lunch okay yeah just dropping this guy's
podcast and say what's going it was cool
so I know the one thing about it though
I think it was emitting Tim because Tim
they have a real quote eight-day talking
person all these other things Tim goes
there every III they got a good
relationship so it could have been maybe
Tim put the word out maybe he just hit
him up said hey I'm on the show when I
come or I don't know I'd have to ask Tim
as well so let me MJ you have any any
more questions how do you know you're
good all right and I'll you're sure you
sure you're good okay all right so I
have to make sure so one final question
for you which I like to ask all of our
guests because I think it's a it's kind
of a unique question to ask everybody
because a lot of people they they really
have that they kind of think about it so
if you could live in one video game or a
fantasy world what would it be
I'm talking about like would you want to
be in the wonderful world of Harry
Potter would you want to be with the
lens of Star Wars Mass Effect's would
you want to be you know halo Tekken I
don't know what Mortal Kombat would like
we're like Marvel what would you would
you say is that one of the things you
would like to do that is a great damn
question that's an extremely good
question probably I've got a little bit
um let's see oh man
all of those um just what I don't
practical out the practicality out the
window like my my health in my life's a
university you can walk out the door and
get destroyed like get Thanos yeah yeah
but besides that living I don't know
living probably in a Marvel would be
kind of cool because just for an
everyday person in Marvel like even even
though like off characters like you just
you could see so much cool stuff
randomly you can be out in a slice of
pizza and see like spider-man to swing
it by around like you know doing crazy
stuff the only thing about that like I
said is that like you your city may be
destroyed like every week after city may
be destroyed like every single week so
that's the only thing about it but I
think Marvel would be
really really fun be just because the
the randomness that can happen in a
universe I mean everybody there's so
many superheroes you know and so many
things that can happen unlike a
universal level you can have aliens go
up one day then the next day it's a mad
scientist and a day a two days later
it's some sea creature you never know so
I think it'd be pretty fun he'd never be
a dull days Everett you ever think that
their insurance was really high they're
like super insurance I know right it has
to be some insurance paid the act you
know that office in the middle of like
tomorrow where universes on so I don't
know but yeah it will be fun never adult
I can't think of the the TV show there's
a TV show that it's essentially a bunch
of guys that work in an office building
and they build tech to protect
themselves from like things that happen
in those types of universes it was a
comedy I'm blanking on the name of it oh
man I don't it's gonna yeah when you
figure it out shoot me a message I'll
look I'll look it up I know I know
exactly the person that it was really
cool concert it was really good it was
it was their first a full season and
then they they exited it which is kind
of annoying but Vanessa superhero
insurance like like like cuz wouldn't be
got a cool to find like the backstory on
how that weird about a backs would be
like a a show did show like how'd it all
work I guess far like an insurance
company didn't sure like supérieur
that's what that's why I liked watching
it cuz it was kind of cool it was like
what happens when when Batman decides to
fly over an area and drop debris in and
then the guys are like oh you can pull
out this umbrella that protects your
head from like you know dropping debris
and stuff like that was it was really
cool I'm gonna have to get the name an
auto message it tonight okay
so uh so tell us where where can people
find you alright so um you know well ptk
blame on xbox live my first and last
name on Twitter as well follow me on
Twitter um that's kind of the hub you
can everything is going to my youtube
channel you can always find it there
first anything post updates recently
I've been asking you know that
give me feedback on any way to improve
the show good or bad you know I'm not a
sensitive guy so I'll take you guys give
me use it to try and you know make the
show better so just taking suggestions
here and in I xbox live obviously what a
game give me their ptk blame across the
or so uh then Saturday's every Saturday
6:00 p.m.
Arizona time I'm sorry I'm not doing it
time for each individual times oh but
you'll figure it out get yourself you
know googling whatever the case may be
every single Saturday so I appreciate
being on the show today man you guys are
all amazing this is a cool concept man I
feel like everybody should want to be on
this show so I'm definitely gonna make
sure you know make my you know people
that follow me aware of the show because
you guys do a great job of your awesome
house as well I think thank you very
much I really appreciate you Tom Pete
what's up it's all Pete oh yeah
definitely of effort team effort trust
me I wouldn't I would never be doing
this if it wasn't for for you guys for
back for backing me up and and like you
know doing everything that we do
together
so I appreciate it thank you guys so um
so L once you tell us where were where
you are and when we're gonna see you
again on mixer all right well I'm
typically everywhere l Baguio 208 and
hopefully tomorrow again I'll stream my
stream for about an hour today yeah I'm
a mixer Twitter and hopefully I have a
schedule soon so yes okay watch Oh what
just goes right Oh what's your schedule
oh my god like yeah I just like turn it
on for whatever reason earlier but yeah
I need a real schedule well I'm happy
that you're back happy I'm happy to see
your smiling avatar MJ working with fund
you find me on Twitter at Bay TMJ or we
can find me on Twitter at MJ as a boss
I'll be back on twitch here and probably
a week or so or maybe even a couple days
because I just said everything up in my
dorm I configured everything able
management so I should be starting up
again soon excellent
awesome the the college dorm man so
excellent happy happy that you're you
know you were able to come back and you
know with that amazing beard a crater
scared the cradle-to-cradle spirit is
that we're gonna yell it the Kratos oh
man if you if you never poor if you have
a Kratos Spears
by Christmas I'll give you 20 bucks I'll
PayPal you 20 bucks so our last member
of our table who was who was unable to
be able to come tonight it was a
old-school style
he is you know he got nailed again with
another night shift so hopefully he's
back very very soon old-school style
he's on Twitter and he also has a
podcast called old-school Tech Talk on
YouTube if you guys wanted to check him
out he's pretty cool he's pretty awesome
I am now though SN al why do you can go
check me out on pretty much everything
on Twitter Instagram Facebook on
Facebook twitch I'm on Twitch Monday to
Friday from 7:00 to 10:00 unless I am
here doing this podcast with everybody
so by all means come check me I hit that
follow button I like to thank all of our
viewers for coming today to hang out and
you know keeping that at that Chacho
which is awesome I really appreciate you
guys coming in it's pretty great
and I would to say we're gonna have the
episode up on iTunes Twitter and Twitter
Spotify and all that stuff come
Wednesday morning if you want to go
follow us to get notifications it is
stream table that is our twitter handle
for some reason why roundtable with the
stream team was just too long and it
wouldn't work so i had to figure out a
smaller way to do that for everybody and
if anyone has any questions that they
want to ask yes' or anything like that
for what we have in the future please by
all means send us an e-mail at around
table stream team at gmail.com I have
that open for anyone that wants to shoot
an email in and we're you know we're
there and we're taking questions
just a reminder iron those podcast is on
it's Sundays at 11 a.m. Eastern Standard
Time
go check out Lords of gaming dotnet we
have multiple different you know
articles and things like that gaming
news tech talks video game reviews our
podcasts are bold we have a lot of stuff
up there that I can't tell you how much
I see the authors convert conversing and
editors I mean the effort that those
guys put in it's crazy and it's awesome
yeah and words as well you guys are all
got your with a really really good set
of guys so yeah they're amazing they're
one of my favorite favorite podcast to
watch with a consistent basis and I
don't want to hear a video yeah they're
great group of guys and I'm telling you
some of the conversations that they have
are just it's so funny this last week oh
my god I can't tell you I was crying for
probably about a good hour to it when
they were going through it it was pretty
great yeah so and just remember
everybody thank you very much like I
said follow us on Twitter and remember
everybody dream big and keep on gaming
so have a great one
and we'll see you guys later where's out
everybody